Is it safe or a cancer patient to drink out of copper cups?
I've seen a lot about using copper and copper cups, I imagine, as a natural antibacterial.
No, the answer is no, it's not.
No, I think it's safe for a none-cancer patient to drink out of copper cups.
So the copper that one would receive if you drink out of copper cups, what type of copper are you getting?
Well, first of all, you're not going to leach much copper if you're drinking cold water out of a copper cup.
It's really not going to leach much copper at all.
That effect, you could measure, you know, a lot of people have copper pipes in their house.
But if you measure the amount of copper that is in the water, it's pretty slim.
Though in the hot water pipes, if you have copper pipes, you might have a higher amount of copper in that water.
And I don't want anybody to go and change their pipes in their house.
The copper, the type of copper that you would receive, if you, if the copper leached off of the cup into the water,
as an iod would be an elemental copper that is not readily absorbed.
So again, your minerals that you receive, the, you know, the periodic table of elements copper is there.
So as iron, people would also use this same argument to trick to use iron cookware.
I'm going to use my cast iron pan because I'm getting iron from my cast iron pan.
Well, you're probably getting more iron from your cast iron pan than copper from your copper cup,
because you're heating your cast iron pan, so you're probably getting more leeching of the iron into your food from the cast iron pan.
But you don't use a cast iron pan to get that iron, the elemental iron that you'd give from a cast iron pan,
and the elemental copper that you give from a copper cup is not readily absorbable.
It's not how we're supposed to be getting our minerals.
It's like saying I'm going to go out and eat some dirt this afternoon.
I'm going to just go down to my garden and take a big handful of dirt and eat that because I need some minerals.
So I'm going to eat dirt.
Matter of fact, there's a condition in children that's called Pika.
Pika is from a Latin word that means dirt eater.
And children will bring dirt and eat dirt out of houseplants when they're mineral deficient.
However, they're not getting much mineral out of dirt.
Again, we're not supposed to eat dirt.
Plants eat dirt, and then they change the minerals in the dirt.
So there's minerals in soil.
So you're the plants take the minerals from the soil and convert it into a different form.
It's a double bonded to typically a glycine or another amino acid.
And then we eat plants or your herbivore cow eats that plant.
And then it has minerals in the muscle.
So you can get minerals from eating a good grass fed cows.
You could get minerals from eating your vegetables.
But we don't get minerals from eating dirt.
Nor do we get minerals from eating, drinking out of copper cups.
Nor do we get minerals from eating out of cast-hired pans.
Those would be elemental minerals.
And they would not be readily absorbed.
And if they are absorbed, they're not going to be readily available to be transported into cells.
They can cause havoc.
So I am not a fan of some of these Instagram posts.
I'm sure this is where you're not this.
There's a lot of even doctors out there that are saying we should be drinking out of copper cups.
Because copper is good for us.
Well, first of all, cancer patients do not want excess copper because copper, as a mineral,
got received the right way through plants in a double bonded amino acid form.
Is necessary for our body as so many trace minerals are.
But it is what it does is it stimulates growth.
So cancer patients, I don't want cancer patients to take supplements with copper in them anyway.
And again, the form of copper that you'd get from a piece of copper would not be the right form.
Good lead to excess copper.
You could have genetic issues where it causes more problems with excess copper.
Because you don't transport copper very well.
And copper toxicity is extremely common.
So that's why I rather have a person be taking zinc because zinc will push out excess copper.
There's a delicate balance between zinc and copper.
And many times because people are zinc deficient, they'll store more copper.
Copper toxicity can lead to muscle aches and pains and arthritic problems and brain disorders.
All sorts of things from copper toxicity.
It's very, very covered.
And it could be a big issue.
So the whole thing about drinking it out of copper cups and eating it out of cast iron.
We use cast iron, but I don't use it to get iron.
And I don't use copper cups because we don't need elemental copper.
I don't think you're getting much on of it.
You got to remember this lots of ridiculous fans out there that have no basis in human physiology.
But natural doctors jump on the bandwagon of these things.
Kind of foolishly and make themselves out to be deep thinkers sometimes.
And I've been guilty of that too.
We have to be careful of what we're pushing.
We got to really think about it from a metabolic physiological standpoint.
Does that make sense?
So the answer is no.
I would not do that.